celebrating the contributions and
influences of tonopitasi and it's the
first Workshop in the reunion program
and satisfiability which actually took
place during the covet so this is an
opportunity for people to be here in
person from that program and uh I'd like
to thank the organizers for this work
for all the work they did in organizing
this workshop and these are antonina
Paul beam Jeff Edmonds Ian Mertz and
Robert Robert yes okay looks like a type
of oh what it's true uh okay so
but all right
um so first of all happy birthday to
Tony maybe we could walk a round of
applause
enough for more boring things food is
provided before the first talk enjoying
the breaks for lunch or on your own uh
we ask you know not to eat or drink in
the auditorium there are lockers on the
far side of the building in the first
floor if you want to leave some stuff
during lunch break uh we have a
videographer or media far who will help
the speakers get set up for talks and
he's sitting over there that's Amid and
um I think this Workshop is hybrid right
my assumption is that Cynthia is for
example giving a talk long distance and
I'd like to also give a special thanks
to our organizing team Ashley and
Elizabeth from Simon's event team but I
don't see them here still let's give
them a round of applause
and now I will give over to Mike to
antonina who really will say something
of substance
Happy Birthday Tony
thank you so much for an excellent
introduction of the workshop
[Applause]
say the traffic was instrumental in
getting things organized and made it
better than
than we thought it would be well
hopefully you'll see so uh just to say
that this is a very very special
Workshop
and they despite all the adversity we
are here now for a big family reunion
you know workshops assignments always
feel like a family reunion but this is
an especially family and especially
reunion
with uh Tony and friends and Tonys first
dogs and students and Grand students
what are the grad students okay but
there are some around and uh hopefully
we will have a lot of fun listening to
the what the family has been been up to
and hopefully Tony has fun
so just a couple of things uh after the
talks today we are going to have a
reception with a little bit extra thrown
in and tomorrow after the talks we are
going to have another special reception
uh colloquially known as Tony Awards
I guess
uh and
um yeah so people on Zoom there are
quite a few people who could only make
it on Zoom
with
things being what they are you're very
welcome to hang out to unmute yourself
especially after dogs during breaks and
just be part of it too
and with that yeah is there any way to
see if people don't have a question I
will be monitoring the questions on Zoom
I'll try to do my best to look uh at you
with one eye and it's my phone with
another so please put and look at the
phone and not being well the usual but
I'm just trying to monitor questions
right
so but please people don't feel free to
mute yourself to ask questions
anything else with that Russell you're
the first
look
hey so I'm gonna talk about
um
uh am I Audible yeah okay I'm going to
talk about algebraic proofs
um I'm not I'm going to be doing a very
superficial job of it hopefully it'll
just like introduce enough of the
concepts to the people giving later
talks won't have to start from scratch
okay
um and I'm taking my title from the
miracle of algebra from that uh
influential philosopher mathematics uh
Walt Kelly
um who demonstrated the power of
algebraic thinking for day-to-day life I
don't know can you read the
should I read the yeah okay so um so
they want to know how many of us are
present so
uh the way to settle how many of us are
present is by Algebra I got my first
grade algebra book here it says let x
equal the unknown
well the unknown that must be
um Herbert sandbox
over in Waycross
he's unknown the best I never heard of
him
better
okay so and then they conclude that
since there are three of them that don't
know sure there are three of them
present which means that that algebra is
a miracle
and I agree with the the conclusion
and I'm gonna see like some miraculous
things uh implications of uh uses of
algebra that made about as much sense as
this cartoon
um so um
uh but you know this is supposed to be
like a very personal workshop and I
really like thought maybe I should give
the the my talk a more personal title
and I see that like
Tony's birthday
is an amazingly popular title on the
schedule
I made this joke last week and uh Tony
said I was embarrassing her Tony
everyone here has spent months figuring
out how to embarrass you
uh we have not yet started
okay so uh
okay
so what is algebra what is algebraic
proofs
um
so uh I guess algebra started as a way
of like dealing with equations and
solving equations so an equation you've
got some kind of function that's maybe a
composition of simple operations over
some kind of algebraic structure
kind of circular there okay
um and you've got these equations and
you want to say what does it mean to
solve equations maybe it means derive
some new equations from the ones that
you have or perhaps like say there is no
solution those equations are
contradictory
and that's when an algebraic proof
system is is away from going from some
representation of equations step by step
uh verifying that new equations are
deducible from previous ones or maybe
that we get a reputation from a set of
equations
and we've we've all
done uh algebraic proofs even if we
didn't know how to by that title you
know like even in uh
High School you were solving systems of
linear equations and variables and you
like did things like derived new
equations from from the existing
equation like we can substitute 2x plus
Z equals zero so Z equals negative 2X
and so we plug that into the first
equation and derived the equation Y is X
plus one
um
and then we can like substitute that in
and and then we get a solution derive a
solution x equals zero y equals one Z
equals zero so that's really like a kind
of like very simple uh system for
dealing with proof system for dealing
with linear equations what are we doing
abstractly we're multiplying each of the
given linear equations by some number
adding up all those numbers uh you know
the multiples and uh deriving a new
equation if it's constant on one side
and non-constant on the other then we've
gotten the contradiction
so um
okay and uh well we could generalize
this to allow those us to multiply by
other polynomials not just uh not just
constants and then we get
um what's called the nostalenza system
group system
so we we're going to be dealing with the
other thing is we're going to be dealing
with equations that
um are not just you know not about
arbitrary variables but about Boolean
variables because we're computer
scientists we like bits so we'll have
the constraints also equation for free
that x i squared minus x i equals zero
I.E XI is either 0 1. and so we'll add
up multiply each of our given equations
by the polynomial add them up if we get
something that's equal to one then we
know that the polynomials can't all be
zero
okay
and this proof system was introduced in
work by being myself young krichek Tony
and whenever from now on whenever
they're I'm gonna like spell people's
names out the first time I talk about
them but after that they're just an
initial Tony if the there are many P's
around Tony is the blue Peak
uh and uh
um I guess everyone but Jan is here
so um okay so and we introduced this in
uh 94.
so why did we introduce the snow storm
inside system okay
um well
what we had we were like interested in
proof complexity in general okay and
there's this kind of like Duality
between proofs and the complexity of
statements of of functions circuit
complexity
in that proofs and formal systems are
limited to talking usually limited to
talking about Concepts that are
expressible in a certain uh format for
formulas
and the uh and so the proofs are limited
to reasoning that can be expressed with
the kinds of lines that are allowable in
the system
and so the intuition is that if we can
like prove a limitation on the kind of
lines that are allowed in the in the
proof then we should be able to show
that a limitation on the on what the
proof system can prove
and we were like carrying out this kind
of you know making this intuition
substantial substantiated uh
you know like and
you know cnfs are easy you know
resolution is based on like CNF they're
easy to prove lower balance for but it
took a little work to translate that to
a resolution lower amount but I'm in
hockey and then uh there are lots of AC
zero lower bounds generalized from Ace
from from
cnfs to depth three or four or five
circuits with unbounded pan and
anthonyors and there were lower bounds
by I tie first first except sir and so
on up to hostat and I'm told like in any
sequence you should just add hostat at
the end
um the next one too and
uh
and this one's missing a p and has a
I forgot to fix this one okay so uh
so
um
uh
uh and this had been like successfully
traded
uh the proof technique random
restriction have been successfully used
uh to prove lower bounds on proofs that
had that kind of line uh that constant
that formula as lines ac0 Fraga okay uh
my first by itai then uh Bellantoni
potassium urquhart and then later work
got a exponentially
and
here's the other class that we had a
lower Bound for at the time okay ac0 mod
P
where you had in addition to
um to those constant depth and nors you
add unbounded fan in uh mod P County
and Roswell swansky had proved a lower
bound uh that was pretty close to the
ac0 lower bound using a different method
algebraic approximation
and so we thought we should just be able
to use this technique to prove that uh
ac0 P prega proofs have a strong lower
bound
so uh
okay
so
um
so what I want to point out is that we
did you know
this was the situation around 1990
unfortunately it's the same situation
now
uh we don't have much strong we have
like
okay some technically uh incomparable
circuit lower bounds but we don't have
real a whole class of things where we
have a real techniques for proving
circuit lower bounds uh and we still
don't have a lower mount for the ac0 on
my P Prego system
so like this intuition worked twice
okay so um
so
so we thought since you know we wanted
to adapt this argument about algebraic
approximations to the to the proof world
so it seemed natural to talk about lower
bounds for uh proof systems that use
polynomials as as lines
foreign
[Music]
and we introduced like a variety of
proof systems trying to do this so
here's the I remember like talking to
Tony about this kind of plan way back in
the early 90s I think before well he was
still a grad student before we even
successfully proved ac0
um frago lower bounds uh at least the
strong ones and I said uh well let's
like look at no stonesauce proofs
uh then we'll just and then say well
what good will that do well then we can
like generalize to know someone thoughts
Bruce to have some small errors in every
line and then somehow we'll get to ac01
P break up first
uh
and I think I I don't think I convinced
her
by this plan
um so uh and I certainly didn't convince
Roman Solinski who I talked to about
this plan next who pointed out that step
B is impossible
um because of the very Roman swanski you
know roswellski technique that I was
trying to to emulate if you look at like
an unsatisfiable formula you look at the
the big end
that's really false okay and so um if
you do their method for approximating it
you get something that has a small no
Stones that's proof from the original uh
formulas and is very very close to
faults and so you you know you just do
that and then you derive faults and it's
approximately true
is approximately correct set so there is
no uh meaningful notion for it you have
to do a lot more work if you want a
meaningful notion uh approximately
correct
uh algebraic proof
so there is no step B
so
actually that was going to be a hard
step so that makes the plan easier
okay so step a we prove lower bounds and
step b c we profit
and this has been a really successful
approach that Tony especially has used
to Great Advantage
so uh
okay so I want to like talk a little bit
about step a uh
how do you prove lower bounds and we
struggled with this for a little while
but we basically found a pretty good
technique pretty quickly
so the idea is that
if you look formally at the what the
what we're trying to to produce is we're
trying to produce these polynomials that
when you multiply by them by the
constraints you sum up and you get one
and if you look at that that's an
equation
and it's kind of a complex equation it's
about polynomials rather than individual
values
but if you're looking for a low degree
contradiction
there you can write down
a polynomial as a kind of vector of
coefficients and formally write down
this one equation as a system of linear
equations in those coefficients
and then you solve that system of linear
equations or you don't necessarily have
to solve them you have to see whether a
solution exists so we could just repeat
this we want to prove a lower bound
until we refute the system of linear
equations and we do that by using the
algebraic proof system that I started
the talk with where you just multiply
things by constants and add them up so
you just have to figure out which
constants data multiply them with okay
and so uh this is a you know for a fixed
degree and a fixed end this is a
polynomial size uh a set of linear
equations in a polynomial number of
variables and uh so that means we can
automize the Nelson's proof system
There's an actual algorithm that if
there's a small proof finds it if
there's no small group uh refutes that
there's no smoke
uh Russell can you hear me and this in
theory gives us a a good way of telling
whether
something has a uh no Stones that's
perfect it also in practice gives us a
great way of telling uh whether
something has a proof you write down
those linear equations you show them to
Jeff admins and then you come back in an
hour
and that's the method that we use for
most of our early papers
okay
so um
okay so uh
so how do we profit from this
uh
so
the original paper uh that I mentioned
gave like one way of profiting is that
we couldn't prove a lower Bound for AC
full ac0 with mod P uh Gates
but we were able to look at ac0 with uh
axioms that corresponded to different
kinds of mod modular reasoning and uh so
if you like see which is derivable with
an ac0 proof but from certain Axiom
schemes we were able to like separate
different Axiom schemes
uh
there was like another way of profiting
that seemed pretty incidental
um
but turned out to be more important than
uh than I knew at least at the time and
that was to look at Oracle separations
of subclasses of tfnp so this is a whole
new set of vocabulary words so I have to
explain what is tfnp
what is the connection to no stone
thoughts and why did we try to do this
anyway okay so what does any of this
have to do with proof complexity so
so this is going to be a digression it's
not going to be obvious that anything
must say for the next minute or two has
anything to do with anything I've said
before
okay so there are a lot of computational
problems that are most naturally viewed
as surge problems like satisfiability or
factorization
and the reason why we don't but
complexity classes are usually defined
as decision problems and the reason why
we don't worry so much about the
distinction is their first
satisfiability you know we want to find
a satisfying assignment but being able
to decide whether it's satisfiable or
not
is equivalent to being able to find a
satisfying assignment
uh Russell can you hear me yes uh hey
it's Josh uh could you could you go back
a couple slides
okay uh
uh one here yeah here uh yeah I was
gonna say
um speaking of uh uh embarrassing Tony I
was sort of hoping that you or maybe
someone was going to talk about this
word automize
now you have you
I was gonna let that one pass
um do you know the history of the word
automized
uh all I know is that Tony told me at
some point she came up with it and and
uh at least at the time I was talking to
her then she had regretted it
Tony do you care to comment
well I have a different version of the
store but
[Music]
no I think it was not in much eyes
then I think it was Mika who changed the
name
okay everybody was happy about the room
um but any yeah so I think he was like
automatized first but no one could say
that
and so I thought there was a workshop
where
ability
yeah
we made a collective decision to change
automatizability to automatability and
maybe in the future we'll reduce it even
further
Otto
hey yeah
um
this prevailing wisdom was challenged at
the boot camp of the science medical
places program where Tony gave a talk
about advertisability
I really didn't know the slide was going
to be so controversial International
yes
[Music]
oh no that was great thanks
[Laughter]
okay so where was I oh talking about
okay so um okay and uh
actually so tfnp is a class of search
problems whose decision problems are
trivial and so you can't really reduce
the search problems the decision
problems trivial meaning that there's
always a yes it's always yes if you look
at is there a solution the answer is yes
and why do we interested in these well
actually a lot of natural surge problems
like factoring or
um
uh finding a collision in a hash
function for
um
for finding another
odd degree vertex in a graph with one
odd degree Vertex or finding an
equilibrium of a two-player game I'll
have this property
so
um
uh uh and so there are actually a lot of
people who around uh late 80s early 90s
introduced this concept uh
so uh I actually have a paper with
monina or in 88 where we do Define this
as very little known fact had no um
uh no historical significance whatsoever
no one actually read the paper and
um and uh Cameron and on different
admins but also not completely unrelated
uh published a paper in 90 called uh
existential
theorem or something like this
computable theorems I forget the name
okay and in the paper I could not find a
trace of that paper it was like a lot of
references to the paper but the paper
itself seems to require you to pay a lot
to pay to be read it so I haven't read
that one
um and then megidio and papa Dimitri uh
uh Define the class with the the name
tfnp in work published in 91 but
sometimes reference is 89. again I
couldn't really find the 89 version
um so uh and so the the properties of
being in tfnp are that you have a
relation R of x y and so uh you should
be able to write down a y and verify it
that R of x y and polynomial time and
for all X there is a y so that R of X Y
so uh there always is a solution and
we're trying to like give an X find any
y so that R of X Y there don't seem to
be any complete problems for tfnp so uh
Christos mainly and his co-authors
mainly introduce subclasses such as PPP
uh given a map from n to n minus one
show that show uh
find a collision now this is kind of
trivial if the map is given explicitly
uh and is polynomial but if the map is
given implicitly as a circuit from
integers from 0 to 10 to integers to
zero to n minus one then this is as hard
as like breaking equation resistance
and there are other subclasses like PLS
and PPA PLS is like finding local Optima
PPA is that problem out uh
uh even versus you're finding another
odd degree vertex in it
okay and the idea was that these classes
were all kind of named after principles
simple principles like the pigeonhole
principle or uh parody argument
and the idea was that the the classes
represented
uh ways of proving that the relation is
total so being in the class meant
there's a kind of proof that your
relation is total via this kind of
thinking
so that's kind of like a natural
connection between these classes and
proofs
proving these the relative strength of
these these kind of principles
so
why did we decide to work on separating
these classes using the stones on slower
bounds
and the answer is really simple
so Tony was a postdoc at ucs2 uh I think
he was mainly working with Sam Boston
myself
but Christos was paying her
and so they wanted to find a project
they could work on together
and so like
intersecting the things that Christos
was interested in and the things Tony
was interested left this one
uh I think that's how it worked and then
why did we decide to use no Stones as
lower bowels to prove the separations
well we had these no zones that's lower
bounds that we wanted to work on and we
wanted them to be good for something
so uh
but it worked amazingly enough so
um yeah
um
so but
many years back many years later maybe
it wasn't just thought that uses tfnp
connection between proof complexity uh
so like Tony has this whole uh
program where she pfnp turns out to be
the link between proof complexity and
circuit complexity in many ways
and where's the link so if you look at
any
proof
so it's going to give you some kind of
like reason why the so-called false
cause problem is always has a solution
so the false cause you're given a set of
causes you want to find one on any
particular instance that's false and
so this is the proof that the the
formula is unsatisfiable is really
saying that this is a total relation
so each prayer system kind of
corresponds to a decision tree tfnp
system class
then uh the non the hard part you can
use lifting
which I won't Define I mean basically
shows that uh query complexity models
and communication complexity models are
kind of dual to each other
are equivalent once you're in the
communication complexity World customer
wigerson games give you a way of mapping
this to Circuit classes
and I'm being very superficial I'm
hoping someone later in the week will
give a more detailed version of this
okay this is another way of profiting
you know carrying out our amazing plan
of proving lower bounds and profiting
because uh Tony and Robert whose last
name sounds a lot like his first name
um as it's been pointed out
um
that showed that uh lifting no sales
degrees gives you a lower bound on
monotone spam programs uh over an
equivalent field
over a corresponding field and uh that
was really like the first technique for
proving lower bounds on on these fan
programs
so uh and there are lots of other
results that use the same kind of
template
um how much time do I have do I have any
time
I'll stop asking
okay so there was another way uh that I
was going to go into it in more detail
uh where we follow tody's plan and
proved lower bounds on uh on
uh pseudo-deterministic algorithms
from
so also like tfnp also played a role in
that uh and since I I only been talking
about Nelson there are stronger proof
systems uh like polynomial calculus uh
there's a story about that too but I
think I'm
if I mean it's like okay okay
so uh this doesn't the story doesn't
have to do with Tony she wasn't a
UCSC at the time but Christos also
motivated uh polynomial calculus
how did he do that he left
and he came here to Berkeley
um and he left his student behind for
Android his student was working on these
kind of like adaptive Logics to handle
learning and forgetting information
um and so he needed uh someone to
actually read his thesis and I was the
closest so I read his thesis and started
thinking about this adaptive information
and said well
can't we do that in the algebraic
setting uh you know where maybe if we
learn something new we just add it as a
new uh a new line in our proof but then
we can like go back and revisit
everything and see how we uh how that
influences the later you know how we
make the Innovation from that and then I
started thinking oh uh
maybe we should have done that all along
uh because you know once you prove
something simple you can go back and
simplify some of the other axioms and
keep on going it's not like unit Clause
uh propagation in in normal size solving
and so uh to find like a more Dynamic
version of no sound it's called Uh
polynomial calculus eventually uh also a
controversial name uh
so and then I showed it to uh Matt Clegg
Who convinced me that what I was doing
was kind of rediscovering a simple case
of Governor basis
and so um
so finally like explain what I was doing
to me
thank you okay so but uh there are other
stronger versions of millstone's offset
Tony has suggested which is to if we
really want to deal with the ac0 mod P
frega let's look at you know someone
says proofs where the the uh the
polynomials aren't that we're
multiplying aren't necessarily written
out explicitly but um are implicitly
defined as arithmetic formulas
now once you start looking at
complicated arithmetic formulas there's
no actual way of verifying that the sum
is equal to one deterministically the
best we know is to use a polynomial
identity testing to do it
probabilistically
and then a few later uh re
um he extended this kind of thinking
even more to the ideal proof system
where you don't actually have to write
down this linear combination at all you
can just write down some algebraic
formula so that when you put plug in
your constraints and I change the name
of the constraint unfortunately uh you
get one but if you plug in all zeros you
get zero so there can't be a solution
that's all in series
speak uh and hopefully Josh will tell to
talk about this one so I want to just
conclude with what I think is the most
fascinating open problem in the area
which is to prove a contradiction from
the following equation which is
intuitively self-contradictory
Tony's just a kid how can we
can we hear like celebrating her whole
career so
um
yeah
so
this is to convince people that it has a
fake resemblance to Tony
I couldn't I couldn't like make it like
have a vapor example to Tony and not
look like a huge monstrosity so I just
chose it to you know the best looking of
the pictures
I'm always the same
thank you so much Russell um maybe uh
well thank you set up questions only
please
yeah
um
oh sorry so just a technical right the
ac0 and fragile bounds of ITI already
bypassed this fact that the
approximating the lines doesn't work so
I think we just need a different way to
do the approximation to start I thought
I'd say this while everybody's here so
somebody will figure it out so
that doesn't work for like ac0 mod P
right but I'm just saying that he came
up with a way to bypass that
uh
yeah
I actually decode I typed papers it's
beyond me I think you spent like your
first year of grad school doing that so
the first three years okay
anyone else remarks
okay thank you so much
[Applause]
and our next speaker
coming from out there
is
Cynthia